oh boy what now we're going deep we're
talking about Jesus
what are we doing here and where are we
gonna go
it's like we just woke up one morning
and then it's welcome to the show don't
ask any questions just go with the flow
make as much money as you can and try
your best not to get broke
copy everything you see on the TV from
the hairstyles to the clothes and don't
think too often just do exactly as
you're told and if you ever get confused
then just turn towards the alcohol
you still hear your thoughts then just
Turn up the radio oh as you learn to
live a lifestyle of drugs sexing rock
and roll
but in all honesty I just need to know
is there more to the cycle than growing
and getting old living and dying just to
leave behind a happy home and a whole
lot of property that somebody else is
going to own
I just really need to know before the
cast gets closed because I'm not willing
to gamble with My Soul nor am I ready to
take any chances these are just simple
life questions and I'm just searching
for some answers like what are we doing
here and what is our purpose how did we
get here and who made us so perfect and
what happens once we go or is this world
already worth it
questions we don't answer because
apparently we don't really have to
there's no purpose to this life in our
existence is merely natural then in that
case please let me ask you did you
create yourself or was it somebody else
who had fashioned you because you're a
being that's impeccable faultless and
unparalleled you're a product of supreme
intelligence and I'm merely being
rational
for there isn't a camera on this Earth
that can come close to the human eye nor
a computer that can compete alongside
the human mind and if the whole world
was to come together we wouldn't be able
to create a single fly
so much crazy who is this guy he's been
bars if the whole world came together we
couldn't make a single fly that's wild
though like we couldn't make something
simple as a fly no this is a really this
guy's this guy's spitting bars yeah I
like I like this guy I [ __ ] with him
what are you drinking taram I'm drinking
white claws which are things I never
thought I would drink but they're good
yeah we still deny a science tries to
justify that all this could come from
none when it's a simple sum zero plus
zero plus zero cannot possibly ever give
you one so from where did all this order
come
but everything has its Origins a maker a
creator of its own I mean the only
reason you're watching this video is
because somebody had to press upload so
we can believe in the Big Bang but I'd
rather believe in he who caused it to
explode
Allah the creator of everything wow that
is wild I'd rather believe in he who
caused it to explode rather than just
like believe everything's just like this
is just how it is ever living the master
the only one who is in control unlike
his creation beyond our imagination and
no he's not a man nor does he have any
Partners in association is on his own
and no he did not ever leave us alone
foreign
just like every manufacturer he left us
with an instruction manual the Quran and
Islam and I'm sorry to jump to
conclusions but it's the only one
possible the only definition of God is
the one and only Supreme Being it's
logical a book with zero contradictions
with Miracles that are both scientific
and historical all revealed over 1400
years ago like the detailed description
of the human embryo the descriptions of
the human embryo and the Quran cannot be
based on scientific knowledge in the
seventh century to the mountains is pegs
holding wow that's crazy like how like
we just watched another video about the
nine craziest facts about the Quran and
that's like another one like how the
[ __ ] do you predict that that that's
what it looks like they had no idea
about anything scientifically back then
and for him to come and bring that
knowledge at the time is wild it's
amazing [ __ ] baby what
but God what I call God and Allah are
they are they in the Muslim religion
this one and the same Allah and God I
don't know Allah and the so although the
Christians and Jews believe in the same
God we just have different
interpretations of Jesus and the Holy
Spirit then Muhammad comes along but
what are we saying around 600 years
later and yeah it was 600 and he's he's
spitting all these Muhammad spitting all
these other facts spitting all these
facts but it has to be from the same God
they have to be the one and the same
yeah I mean it's just it's it's like a
it's a mind [ __ ] when you really think
about it I mean yeah it could be the
same Gods no yeah it was great just this
great power and people just interpret it
differently or I don't know right
because between God and us things get
really convoluted even the things that
Muhammad wrote what very little we know
about them so far had to have been
influenced by his own Humanity had to
have been yeah there's no way for us to
to filter straight from God without
screwing it up somehow because we are so
not godly like he said you know all of
us could come together with all of our
brain power and not create a fly from
nothing mountains is pegs holding firm
the earth below and the two seas that
don't mix in a complete separate flow to
the planets in orbit alternating night
and day as they stay in flow the
expansion of the universe and the
creation of everything from
H2O to the stories of the past and the
preservation of pharaoh to identifying
the lows point in the land where Persia
defeated Rome the gushing fluid that
created man in the glands between the
ribs and the backbone and not a word is
changed it's still the same so please
explain how all this was known over 1400
years ago
to a man who couldn't read or write as
he would recite whatever the Angels
spoke and if you still don't believe
please try to come up with something
that's even close
but you can't so we took God as a
mockery and his Messengers is a joke
scriptures as Legends and tales of the
ancient folk as we live life according
to our whims desires and hopes saying
this life is the only home we will ever
know we will live then died and simply
turn to Bones yo low correction after
the grass dies the rain arrives and it
regrows and Allah promises to do the
same thing to your very soul and bring
you back from your very fingertips to
your toes so I was wondering today what
are some similarities what commonalities
do we have and and I'm seeing them now
that is absolutely one thing that you
know as Christians we do not believe
that this is it we believe that we are
here to do God's work on this planet and
he created us for a purpose and if we
are in tune and we and we try and we ask
we can maybe achieve at least some of
what he hoped for us and then we will be
rewarded with you know internal piece at
the hand at the right hand of God and
sit there and be able to hang out and
he'll know us all by name and bring us
you know just bring us together and
there's without all of our Earthly
worries and all of our [ __ ] and
that's exactly what we just saw in this
video so there are commonalities no 100
there's a ton of common commonalities
between the two religions I want to know
all of them I know well we're going to
keep watching Supreme Being watches us
so close and we are surely being tested
in our wealth our health and our self
and everything that we've been blessed
with so believe for we will surely be
resurrected and be brought back to our
Lord in account for every single deed as
he hands us our books and orders us to
read
[Music]
from the bad to the good and everything
in between you yourself are sufficient
for your own accountability so don't be
mad at me you are the one who thought he
wouldn't come back to me I gave you a
whole life long to search after me but
you were busy and all that which was
temporary so read and Glad Tidings to
all those who believed and if you
disbelief
read and don't let that day be the first
day you find out what your life really
means
read
interesting that's crazy heavy heavy and
beautiful it was a really beautiful
Muslim so the the meaning of life Muslim
spoken word from the channel talk Islam
what is the description of that video
does it give credit to that young man
probably the guy making the video his
name is nowhere there his name isn't in
the description which I find interesting
and I wonder if that's deliberate or
accidental I mean is it he just so
there's there's this song called nobody
it's a Christian song and it's just you
know if you ask me like who do you think
I am with all this like God stuff like
I'm just nobody trying to tell everybody
about God and um it's it's actually
really good Christian song and it's a
little Rocky and I wonder if he had if
it's on purpose that his name's not
there maybe you know that it's not about
him it's about erasing you know or you
know putting myself aside for God is
that what he did there it looks like it
I mean that's that's the best guess that
I would have that's that in itself is a
is a conversation piece that's the the
whole point right do his work don't
worry about yourself do his work and
make an impact good job whoever you are
you're doing it good job buddy all right
thank you guys so much for watching make
sure to follow myself and my mother on
Instagram Sonny fast and Sonny's mother
and join the Discord I have some free
Tech talk tips there and so if you like
this video click sub yeah please I
always feel weird like giving a promo at
the end of a video like this I know but
here's the thing if if people are moved
by it and they're interested in it they
can get more out of it by subbing it's
that simple sub and keep watching all
right and have a few laughs don't get
all serious on us all right thank you
guys
[Music]
gone
[Music]